bonjour jean marc heureuse de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale verte et
france édition spéciale donc consacré à
ce sommet entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden cette rencontre officielle va être
suivie évidemment par le monde entier
que peut-on attendre de ce dialogue
vous voyez à priori c'est quand même un
signal positif que qu'elles veulent
donner les deux chefs d'état dubai
d'année et bannir tout in au monde des
affaires au monde des business on l'a
bien vu la semaine dernière lors du
forum économique de saint pétersbourg il
y avait le monde du business
international qui était là il y avait
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'américains qui
avait obtenu des visas en dépit des
sanctions parce que le marché russe est
important parce que les échanges de
technologies entre les pays entre la
russie l'europe et les états unis sont
importants et ils doivent encore être
développée notamment dans le cadre d'une
sortie de la crise pandémique qui a
touché tous les pays du monde alors joe
biden à a beaucoup conserver de mesures
économiques avaient été prises par son
prédécesseur de l'alt rush sur le plan
intérieur
mais les il a changé du tout au tout sa
lecture des rapports géopolitiques de la
preuve avait commencé vous vous en
souvenez à sortir a essayé de sortir les
états-unis des organisations
internationales
ils n'assistent est à peine au g7 au g20
il avait quitté l'om c'est souvenez-vous
l'organisation de la santé aussi le
bouder l'onu le fmi
c'était vraiment american shirt avec du
protectionnisme à la clé il concevait
les rapports internationaux comme des
rapports ou d accord bipartite alors à
propos de l'europe donald trump ne s'y
intéressaient pas quand tu as le temps
il n'était pas loin de penser que cette
organisation de défense ne servait pas à
grand chose
or joe biden il revient au
multilatéralisme vous avez vu son agenda
le g7 d'abord puis l'otan suite et
maintenant
vladimir poutine parce que je m'adonne
considère que le monde est une grande
communauté qu'on a intérêt à parler avec
tout le monde et qu'en plus c'est
excellent c'est bon pour les affaires le
monde du business attend ce
multilatéralisme alors il va rencontrer
vladimir poutine qui a lui aussi besoin
de parler avec tout le monde parce qu'il
a besoin le faire du commerce
mi-août il a besoin de vendre son gaz
notamment aux européens il a besoin de
faire du collège pendant les années
trump les marchés se fermait et la
russie qu'est ce qu'elle faisait et bien
elle se tourne vers la chine donc il
existe des facteurs qui peuvent
permettre aujourd'hui d'avancer vers un
dialogue plus constructif et renforcer
notamment des échanges économiques
sur quoi précisément peut-on avancer
selon vous alors on va avancer sur un
certain nombre de secteurs économiques
on peut espérer que l'amérique de joe
gilgun par exemple en arrivera à lever
des menaces de sanctions à l'encontre
des entreprises qui travaillent avec les
pays qu'elle a black listés et la russie
et d'inde et pays depuis la sphère
d'ukraine qui est blacklisté dans
certain nombre de secteurs par les
américains l'iran bien sûr est encore
davantage mais c'est un autre problème
cette question des sanctions gène
absolument tout le monde et pas
seulement les entreprises russes où
l'économie russe
elle gêne les industriels américains je
vous disais ils sont venus très nombreux
et ça a frappé tout le monde
ils sont venus très nombreux à saint
pétersbourg il ya une dizaine de jours
il était au forum et tous sont
évidemment dit l'embarras dans lequel il
était une des questions par exemple qui
inquiète le monde c'est la menace
américaine de bloquer toutes les
transactions en dollars
a priori c'est ça paraît peu plausible
sauf que poutine la semaine dernière en
prévision de cette menace de 7 rennais
puis de cette réunion avec buydens a
fait un appel du pied aux en europe 1 en
disant en disant qu'on pouvait très bien
demain si on pouvait plus faire de
commerce en dollar d'affaires du
commerce en europe pourquoi par exemple
ne pas payer le gaz qui circulent dans
ce gazoduc north stream est bien en
euros et non plus en dollars je pense
que le climat avec bye donne va changer
parce que il est très pragmatique et qui
sont intéressés faciliter les échanges
la russie a besoin de vendre son gars je
vous lise elle a besoin d'acheter de la
technologie occidentale et nous
occidentaux les européens d'abord puis
les américains nous avons besoin des
marchés russes le marché restait plus de
200 millions de consommateurs j'ajoute
que l'intérêt des américains n'est
surtout pas de voir la russie allait
s'approvisionner
du côté des chinois comme elle avait
commencé à le faire déjà depuis deux ou
trois ans et quels sont les
sujet qui fâche jean-marc chinois six
minutes les sujets qui fâchent très
rapidement parce qu'il ya des lignes et
des lignes jaunes qui ont été ont été
tracées par tout le monde la russie
n'aime pas évidemment que les
occidentaux viennent lui donner des
leçons de respect des droits de l'homme
la russie accepte mal que l'occident et
notamment l'amérique vient de se mêler
de ses relations compliquées avec
l'ukraine où avec la crimée mais par
ailleurs on sait bien que
l'administration américaine soupçonne la
russie d'être à l'origine de campagnes
de déstabilisation et même d'être à
l'origine des cyberattaques on en a
beaucoup parlé dans votre jaune a donc
les deux hommes vont sans doute parler
de tout ça ils vont parler très
longuement d'ailleurs 1 4h 5h dit on
sait alors c'est assez classique tout ça
mais personne n'est dupe il ya beaucoup
de posture dans tout ça parce que tout
le monde sait que les histoires et les
cultures sont différentes il ya une
deuxième variable évidemment le temps le
temps a été créée par des occidentaux
pour se protéger du régime communiste le
régime communiste s'est effondré et on
peut se demander d'ailleurs à quoi sert
le temps c'est une discussion qui a lieu
chez les européens
mais je replace sont pas d'accord sur la
configuration et sur l'avenir de l'otan
donc il existe des dossiers compliqués
moyen-orient turquie il va falloir
régler tout ça fait un éco système
politique qui pèse énormément sur le
climat des affaires mais vous savez le
maillon faible le maillon faible dans
cette géopolitique que joe biden et
vladimir poutine veulent évidemment
reconstruire le maillon faible c'est
l'europe l'union européenne était car
tenez actuellement entre sa fidélité
historique j'allais dire aux aux états
unis et sa proximité géographique
culturelle j'allais même dire religieuse
avec la russie le général de gaulle
avait parlé de l'europe qui allait de
l'atlantique à l'oural
emmanuel macron avait repris cette
expression il ya trois ans on n'en parle
plus guère et on sait parfaitement par
exemple que l'allemagne a une autre
conception des rapports avec la russie
et avec la mairie merci beaucoup
jean-marc pour toutes ces précisions
c'était à l'édito échos de jean marc
sylvestre consacré au sommet entre la
lumière poutine et joe biden aujourd'hui